Shadow justice secret Tracy Reid is with
us
what what to say what can what can one
say what can you say okay I mean this is
beyond sickening that a nine-year-old
little girl in her own home has been
shot in Cold Blood by a deranged gunman
who just ran in off the street and was
able to kill her and now you know I know
the city of Liverpool I you know visited
there many many times that is a place
with a big heart and a really strong
sense of community and I know the pain
that people in Liverpool will be feeling
today and I know everyone in that City
will want to encourage anybody who has
any information about who this killer
was will go and report that to the
police because frankly K if they can do
this once they can do it again and that
person needs to be got off the street
but for now I think for all of us for in
the studio and watching on on TV our
hearts go out to that little girl her
family it's just it is simply
heartbreaking Shadow Justice secretary
and speaking to the government in the
last hour about whether we are topping
off on knife and gun crime in this
country
well we have clearly we're not I mean
how is the supply of guns uh and knives
so prolific that people can get these
weapons and use them in these ways we we
did some research
um in the labor party just a couple of
weeks ago that showed that prosecutions
and convictions for people using knives
to maim and to kill had actually gone
down rather than gone up and that was
despite the conservatives being elected
on a Manifesto pledge to toughen it up
three strikes and you're out they said
actually that has not happened and when
the system goes soft uh on that kind of
killing on that kind of crime criminals
take courage and they go out and do more
of it we absolutely have to understand
what is going wrong in the system look
to every single part of it but
fundamentally we need to be prosecuting
and punishing and preventing in a way
that is not happening with this
government because they cut 21 000
police off our streets they've allowed
nearly 60 000 a backlog of 60 000 cases
in the courts if we don't prosecute
we're not preventing we have to do it uh
Sharon Graham um we had on the program
at yesterday General Secretary of unite
and she was talking about the docker
strike particularly which talked about
other strikes as well she says she'd
like labor to support workers in a more
upfront way
well labor will support workers by
putting forward proposals to how we can
deal with the cost of living crisis that
is really affecting people right now
over this past decade this Tory decade
it has been the lowest decade for wage
growth since the Great Depression of the
1930s so wages have been held down
they're falling now in real terms and on
top of that we're now seeing prices in
the shops hitting 10 inflation projected
uh incredibly to hit closer to 18 in the
new year and energy prices rocketing so
what was an average household Energy
bill of a thousand pounds a year ago now
projected to hit 5 000 pounds in April
the labor party has proposed a fully
costed plan to freeze Energy prices so
families do not have to face that four
thousand pound increase in costs that so
many of us so many people the majority
of people simply cannot afford but
where's the government the government
the two contenders to be the next prime
minister and this seems to have gone on
for months and months now are just
fighting each other like rats in a sack
and refusing to come up with with
proposals to help people it's not true I
mean quality who is uh widely tipped to
be the next Chancellor he's apparently
met with at least one energy boss last
week they're looking at a hundred
billion pound package now you're going
to say that that was Labor's idea and
they've stolen it from you well they I I
know I know he and and the current
Chancellor the team as a whole we met
with the energy companies and yet they
put out a statement the same day that
they weren't going to come to any
agreements on it people cut the the
price cap increases this Friday you know
two days away where's the government
we've got a zombie government that is
doing nothing because this in terminal
leadership contest has gone on and on
and on and we've got you know the
flip-flops we've seen from them as well
originally Richie sunak said he wouldn't
cut vat from energy bills when we
proposed it now he says he will Liz
truss says she wasn't going to give what
she called handouts help to people that
really struggling now she says she might
you know more flip-flops from these two
than you'll see on the beach in Brighton
but where are the hard ideas where are
the decisions this is the government
when you practice that in America you
should have said I'm not going to use
that line that was a shocker
um but you say they're doing nothing and
they're a zombie government but then in
the same breath you say that the
chancellor is making meeting with the
Energy company that we didn't take any
decisions what was the point they are
the government we are the opposition
they are the government they are
supposed to be taking decisions we've
come forward with a fully costed plan
for how we would freeze Energy prices uh
over these coming months so families
don't face a 4 000 pound increase uh the
the vast majority of British households
simply cannot afford people are
terrified or spoken to constituents in
in my own patch in Croydon North they
are terrified about how they're going to
be able uh to afford this they can't
afford it and if people can't pay
because they can't afford to pay what's
going to happen to the energy companies
anyway we have to keep the system
working we need a government that will
act rather than this zombie government
that is doing nothing okay quick thought
a thought on what's Happening as far as
Ukraine is concerned gas prices have
gone up 34 this week we don't get our
gas directly from Russia but the
wholesale cost of gas goes up generally
on the open market
um how much longer can we afford to keep
pressure on Russia as opposed to people
being able to heat their homes here in
the UK we absolutely have to maintain
Unity across the the Western World
against this illegal and brutal invasion
of Ukraine by by Vladimir Putin if he
gets away with this then who's next we
simply cannot allow that to happen
because ultimately the freedom of all of
us is in Peril there are two things we
need to do
um relating to the to the energy crisis
that is resulting at least in some part
from that the first is to look at how we
can freeze prices over these uh coming
winter months and labors already come up
with a fully costed plan for that we
would love to the government to recall
Parliament so we can put that on the
table and get it sorted but but they're
refusing but secondly when need to look
at how we can take back more control of
our own energy in this country and that
means investing in more Renewables
currently only six percent of our total
energy comes from Renewables in France
it's three times that amount the more
that we control our own energy Supply
the less we are prone to be the victims
of of very unreliable International we
must leave it there it's great to see
you as always thanks very much indeed
thank you